we did it guys Gregory's here and John
and we just literally are coming back
from viewing Suicide Squad getting a lot
of controversy already just because of
the fact that it has a low score on
Rotten Tomatoes nobody hates DC DC
especially Rotten Tomatoes they hate it
we will be doing a spoiler review this
weekend we just get a quick review up
right now I liked it I thought it was
fun here's what I'll say the first thing
I told John we were walking out we're
going down the escalator I said that
everyone's right everybody rating give
it a rotten capsule totally agree with
them everybody give it fresh I was like
mmhmm I couldn't talk to you out I'm
having fun and I also couldn't talk you
out of having some major problems but
yes let's the starters the film is very
choppy it's messy it's chaotic it's all
over the place between present moment
and flies on even what most of the
scenes seem truncated like the pacing is
like really like let's move this along
it does have all that however I thought
it was it I had a blast watching it I
thought like the music choices were fun
up some of the Doug don't always work
but I think it's old sometimes I felt
like for the most part I thought it was
really really fun
Will Smith as Deadshot was one of my big
concerns actually because I was like
this might be like a distracting
celebrity to put in here amongst the
rest of the cast without like him having
to try anything to steal the show he
kind of does he leads the show who like
he he is the lead of this movie and I
think he does a really really good job
he brings that celebrity Will Smith
charisma charm to the role of Deadshot
that's like ruthless hitman she's still
new he like nails it he's so badass he's
funny
margot robbie a lot she's getting a lot
of credit to you as Harley Quinn I've
seen every episode of batman the
animated series i've seen a lot of her
other appearances and like other DC
works and I think that margot robbie
totally embodied this role of Harley
Quinn when I was watching this film I
felt like I was watching like a fan make
this movie I felt like it was a
fanfiction kind of
you know because I do these flashbacks
and Batman shows up and as the guy who's
a huge fan of Batman see I didn't feel
this would be EVs I don't like me yes
but with this one I was like this is
more for people like me like who just
love to see like all these characters
come together there's choppy stuff and
then there's tributes and there's no
Marge's and there's there's little
treats for the fans so even though the
film is a mess even even though the
pacing is off and everything I still
thought that it was really really
entertaining the messiness kind of
worked for me and sometimes it doesn't
because sometimes the messiness is like
well yeah this is a good story about a
bunch of like dysfunctional criminals
it's so this one's gonna feel a little
chaotic
I like the introduction of all the whole
Suicide Squad members not saying they
fully took advantage of each member of
The Suicide Squad throughout the film
I still like their introductions though
I say something just keep talking
journals I like the Suicide Squad I
think everybody they got to be a member
of the suicides but even the characters
like katana who don't really we don't
ever get to know who she is except for
like the the one time she shows up and
they're like that's who she is Jane
Hernandez is Diablo I thought was I
thought he did a really good job in the
performance all the actors brought
personality and like when they do get to
be together like you can feel the
magical yeah like they are a cool team
and when that stuff gets to shine like
you're like that's the stuff I wanted
actually right before watching this film
I hire I saw that the runtime was two
hours and three minutes and I was like
man I'm stealing BBS for like two and a
half hours yeah they probably were like
we you guys need to cut down Suicide
Squad because if you do get that sense
the whole time when I was watching this
movie I felt like these scenes were
probably significantly more fleshed out
we're probably where the actors really
got to play cuz the actors do such a
great job in these roles actors are
really on their a game everyone's
natural they have a lot of chemistry and
it's just you know the editing gets in
the way of that you know the pacing it
felt like that's where the the biggest
conflict happened was with the editing
as I was watching this movie I was kind
of reading it in my head I felt like the
placement of scenes was kind of off at
times I felt like they shot a lot I felt
like they shot
yeah a lot of stuff and then they were
whoa now we gotta Jam this into two
hours we gotta like cut down on pretty
much every see every scene does feel
like is pared down to like the most
important ten lines and it's not as bad
as it as it can be a link like PBS has
scenes like that where you're like what
is this like every scene is still a
scene it's just some of them feel you
can tell that they were pared down yeah
I didn't feel like this was a lazy film
no no no really yeah I thought this one
really did try I know people said the
BBS extended cuts better I really feel
like there's a great film like a
genuinely great film in this movie of
David Ayer's original cut probably the
film that I got really excited for is in
here somewhere yeah yeah it's just
buried under a lot of rejiggering it
really just feels like it's the editing
that's the main issue for me yeah
totally it feels like somebody who
remixed the story and then drowned it in
music is like that's the thing where the
music gets tiresome is there a scene
where I'm like this is really cool and
there other scenes around like it sounds
like somebody told you to put another
cool song in it does kind of drown
itself in style and it all starts to
taste the same for me after a while
which is just a bummer cuz you see it's
all on the screen all the ideas are
there all the set pieces are there all
the production design is there like
everything they need is there it's just
kind of yeah like I really I really feel
like the final product was like the way
the scenes were you know laid out and
structured I don't feel like that was
how the original script went I just
don't get that sense because I'm like
everyone seems to be doing a really good
job yeah it's like everyone just runs
even trying this film was in the Final
Cut is what they call it you know like
Captain Boomerang Jai Courtney the role
I like this guy yeah I'm really enjoying
like Ghibli let him be Australian all
the day because he's really fun to watch
it's something - I laughed a lot in this
movie occasionally was unintentional
most of the time it was it was
intentional humor and I found myself
like laughing quite a lot at this film
it's not like a comedy it didn't feel
like out of place jokes ever which I
really admire too cuz I was worried that
they were gonna try to like infuse
humour we're out of place humor but I
thought the humor came from the
characters was really well done some of
it did feel a little out of place for me
but that's again it felt like an editing
thing it felt like they just cut a scene
short on a joke
sted where most of the jokes come from
you know it seems like it's true to the
characters and they are funny like
everybody gets a moment to have
personality and to get a moment to make
us chuckle you know your rabbit.the
anything for me like it felt like David
Ayer got to make the film you wanted to
make but when it came to the final
headed the final cut that's when Studios
would like stepped in we're like okay
you trim this down but like a half hour
from the Hollywood report like you know
all movie news is up for negotiation
because like Studios just flat-out lied
to us now like you know they can tell
you anything they want so I don't know
what the the truth truth is Hollywood
Reporter basically said after BBS they
listen to all the criticism and they got
trailer park whose the company that cut
the trailers for Suicide Squad when
people went nuts over that trailer with
all the Queen music they got them to do
a cut that was basically more along the
lines of the complaints more fun more
snappy you know more action stuff like
that and then they had the David Ayer
cut and then they tested both of them
and kind of arrived at a cut in the
middle of the two they kind of melted
them together and it feels like that one
thing that would bother me sometimes
especially with Viola Davis it was great
in the movie she's fantastic
Yallah Davis and Will Smith I felt like
a little too often they were reminding
us that they were bad guys and I don't
know and I felt like why don't you just
show us like why they're bad instead of
come on slowly just telling us they're
bad guys
we're an r-rated superhero movie could
have been really but they would have
been told you okay David Ayers previous
films are oh like a [ __ ] our guy does
is gritty criminal movies and you don't
need to make it super blow your super
gory but it wouldn't be so much more
effective if you just showed us that
these are bad people
yeah instead of just kind of telling us
introducing to them us to them in a
prison and Killer Croc I thought like I
know he's like a thuggish criminal like
as I've seen the animated series yeah
but in this one I felt like they just
made him purely like a thug doesn't
really have intellect
yeah he's grunts the whole movie and
this guy's really he kind of just stands
and every scene and goes yeah it's
somebody and that's about it and this
stuff with enchantress that I mean
people were complaining a lot about that
and I really feel like simple trick
could have been editing I told John for
her cuz especially when she really gets
to be enchantress it's like the audio
sinks a little off in the effects are
wacky and she's kind of drowned in
effect so I don't know what that
performance is really but I feel like
the first half with enchantress the
stuff was good yeah yeah before before
this stuff before this other character
gets introduced thats related to
enchantress that that's when it like
yeah that's her whoa what with
enchantress like there's something
really spooky effects some really creepy
moments with her it's like well this is
like a out of legit horror film yeah
yeah yeah they're really you know taking
taking hold of the voodoo witch vibe and
that gives a new flavor you know to
movie like you know honestly a character
I like that I wasn't expecting to have
any interest in was Joel Kinnaman is
character Ricky yeah he's in this movie
like more than I thought he was actually
really enjoyable to watch I felt like he
brought layers to the role that were you
know it made for a really enjoyable
performance these roles that could be
easily like oh we have to do with this
military guys the whole time just let it
be the Suicide Squad and I actually
didn't mind having him around like he's
a good foil and he drove the story in a
cool way
that's what I mean like all the
everything's there I'm sure all he sure
all the footage is there because like
that scene that they were like teasing
in the trailer would Joker and dr.
Harley Quinzel you know like it Harleen
Quinzel before she's ever ever becomes
Harley Quinn that scenes cut down like
10 seconds but I'm sure like they
probably filmed that scene for quite a
while it was a lot more dialogue this is
a movie it just doesn't seem like this
should be a walk in the park for David
Ayer this should be fun for him and like
you know some of the problems they just
yeah it's like it seems like
everything's here and it's just been
jiggered by you know paranoia and I
guess the biggest letdown in terms of
marketing and height wasn't let down
it's more of kind of like I wish this
was there
I wish what's Joker because when I saw
the trailers I was worried that what the
film did is what I was worried who's
gonna happen which is Joker is kind of
like his own thing going on where we cut
back to every once in a while that's
it's very brief every scene Jay Leno has
is super briefly you can tell this guy
did a lot of work on the Joker yeah he
has these like animalistic kind of like
hunting his prey sometimes moves like a
snake or like a tiger like hunting him
down people he's manipulative like you
could tell there's a lot of layers and a
lot of depth but Jerry let her dick
create otherwise like that's why I did
all the crazy method acting
[ __ ] but this movie does not give time
for us to really see all that like
dedication and hard work he did I
enjoyed those scenes but it is true the
way it appears now and again they said
like I think he said they cut a lot of
his scenes out it seems like you could
cut him out of this cut of the movie and
it wouldn't really make that much every
tip yeah honestly I would have have
liked for them to just hint at Joker and
allude to the Joker maybe do some of
those cool shots were like that's the
back of the joke rather than seeing the
Joker in this one I guess the
disappointing part about the Joker and
this is like you could tell chair
loaders doing an amazing job but with
the screen time they give him it's just
not enough they like quickly cut through
his scenes and when I when I'm watching
it it's like I kind of don't care about
you everyone else like the whole Suicide
Squad story way more interesting than
whatever the hell you got going on right
now yeah this is kind of a distraction I
don't actually know how I feel about his
performance and I would have liked a few
more scenes to tell cuz I can tell you
did a lot of work I don't know how I
feel about his take and I'm just kind of
left there yeah there are a couple
scenes where I'm like that's really cool
in there a couple scenes rose like it's
so short at the end of the day when I
was watching this film I was having a
great time I thought it was a lot of fun
despite my criticisms I would still
totally recommend you go watch this
movie for yourself people clap when the
movie was done when I was walking out of
the theater during the crisis go to the
bathroom fast
everyone was chatting and in the lobby
and everyone seemed very enthusiastic
about it after coming off of BBS like
six months ago this is a much better
step in the right direction you see like
a cinematic universe it's still a bit
[ __ ] up but it seems like they [ __ ]
it up but it's right direction yeah it's
it's more it's a lot more fun there was
a director's cut for this that I'm sure
they will release I'd be on top of that
right away
yeah all this movie needed was more time
to flesh things to let things play out a
little bit more it's like it could have
been a balance of like chaos and then
flesh because like there's that bar
scene you see in this yeah in the
trailers that that's like the only time
the movie I don't see that feels like a
legit scene that nobody [ __ ]
the editing is a big part of a film but
that's the one that's my really only big
problem with the film is the way it was
edited it's I can trace everything back
to that because he's a SAG besides quad
it's like they could have handled the
unsung better and that's that's a pretty
big issue in this movie and I feel like
again it's all there it's just they
really poorly distribute time certain
characters just kind of get shafted and
then like disappear and reappear my
point with that though is that that's
the only major flies I see with this
film it's you can trace them just that
one thing I feel like everything else in
there even the stuff that didn't really
get to shine that you can still feel
that it was probably really great in the
end today you know I did enjoy this film
I do recommend it and I guess if we had
to give a rating 80 out of a hundred
schmoes uh yeah I mean if you're if
you're big DC fan I think you'll
probably enjoy this if you're just
coming in like me where you've read a
few comics and you like the movies but
you're not this isn't your bread and
butter you might be a little more
frustrated by this because as a movie
it's it's a mess but I still had fun and
I left feeling good the whole excuse of
like this movies more for the fans and
not you know I don't think it is I don't
think that's a good excuse ever however
for this particular movie I feel like it
will apply more than previous DC films
anyway keep a lookout for our spoiler
review if you're new to the channel
subscribe Jon's Jerry and he's on
facebook.com slash Blum house yeah
alright guys well it's late at night
tomorrow with destiny